so this is
uh
yeah all right
here we go
i think i should just
call as myself
okay
well i won't say my name
physical therapy yeah is this uh
yes all right so i'm interested in the
uh do you do the any of the pelvic floor
therapy
we do all right uh what time can i come
in
um so would you be a new patient
i would like to be an older patient uh
in my late fit well mid 60s probably
my well i am i'm 65.
gotcha gotcha okay okay um are you
currently still uh working or do you
have a
hmo
um
i do but i'm not uh i'm going to take
some time off work are you willing to or
can you come to work to do this like is
it better that i'm working while you're
dealing with my pelvis or is it
should i take some time off
what is better so the only reason i ask
this just because of your age would put
you in under medicare and we aren't able
to see medicare patients unless um they
fall under certain um exceptions
um so that's why i was asking about if
you were currently still working or had
a private insurance
as your primary um or if or i could pay
cash i'm gonna pay cash for this
yeah so i mean we are out of network
with insurance so it would be you know
of these upfront costs but we still
would need you to fall under one of
those exceptions yeah i have hmo i have
an hmo so what i'm gonna do is and and
then i would uh
do i lie my tummy or my back
to get to my pelvis
well because i'm thinking the best way
in is through my uh
i don't know the the proper language he
used through my anus is that is that the
best way in
um it would just kind of depend on your
condition but it really my i use um
does it matter what kind of uh
conditioner i use because why would that
matter because for some people um they
do lie on their back some people do lie
on their stomach like i said um it would
really just kind of depend um i wouldn't
be able to tell you really many
specifics because i'm not but would they
would they put the finger would they put
is it i don't know
who i'm talking to but would i would you
put your finger in my anus and then
decide or would the decision be made
before
the finger was in there
it would be made beforehand yeah but all
right
but do i come in with
uh
so just
walk me through this
yes so the way that we would what i can
help you with starting you know is set
up for your appointment um it would be a
90 minute evaluation
so in that 90 minutes how long would
there be a finger in my anus
um i wouldn't be able to tell you for
sure i'll hang on will you check
um
yes um actually i think it would be best
maybe if one of our pt's spoke to you
instead because they would be able to
answer yours oh yeah i would like to
talk to the person that's going to put
the finger in my anus please i'll hang
up yes thank you um so right now um we
don't have anyone who would be able to
talk to you until about 1 30 um just
because they're currently with patients
oh will you talk to me then give you a
call back will you talk to me then
um i can but i like i said i can't
answer some of your questions just
because i don't know so you wouldn't you
personally would not you personally
would not be putting your finger in my
anus
correct yes oh okay all right i'm just
writing this down slowly pardon me what
did you say i said i just worked the
front desk so yeah oh so but if i stayed
at the at the front if i was on the desk
you could do it then so i could i don't
have to be in the
no so you would be in a treatment room
with someone and they would you know be
the ones who would be put their finger
in but they would put their finger in my
anus
what it is your diagnosis
pardon me
um what were you needing pelvic floor
physical therapy for pelvic floor
diagnosed with something were you
referred to us by your doctor
no my uh daughter told me about uh
just put it up on the screen in front of
me so i i called and i just wanted to
know if i wanted to like who puts their
finger on the uh
who would do that
it would be one of our physical
therapists if they if it was something
that was you know necessary for your
condition but like i said i just wanted
to ask questions
oh there isn't
nobody has put their finger in my anus
so nobody's done it before this would be
the first time
okay but are you experiencing like
pelvic pain
do you have how do i know until somebody
puts their finger in there
well typically people uh know that they
are experiencing perfect pain or are
referred to us by their doctor which is
something we do need to have on file for
your appointment do you want to speak to
my daughter
does she
like handle your appointments or your
she's the one who she's the one who told
me uh about this
okay i mean god that would be fine
totally up to you
i just want to kind of get an idea of
your like uh health history my health
history
yeah well
in terms of like if you have like rectal
pain prostatitis well if that depending
on well that's why but that's why i'm
that's why i'm asking you
i don't have rectal pain i don't have
rectal pain but that's won't that depend
on the size of the finger or the like
the nails or whatever like that
well some people have you know that pain
coming into the appointments already and
that's why no
no that's not me i'm looking to come
into the appointment and get that pain
got it okay yeah i know uh then speak to
my daughter
here's my daughter this is jackie hello
hi i'm just trying to get a better
understanding of like diagnosis wise
here um what was the need for pelvic
floor physical therapy all right i heard
no i heard that it was something that
could be beneficial for people that have
anal leakage
okay got it um give me one second
like a like a plug
like a plug
she's typing
anal leakage
yeah whoops
did it again
all right
you have a tissue
jackie you have a tissue
no
hello
okay so um
yeah we could set up an appointment but
like i said we whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa
this is more than i've ever had
okay
anyway uh did you speak to my daughter
i'm sorry what did you speak to my dad
it's all wet
it's all wet here uh did you speak to my
daughter
uh briefly
honey just give me a napkin or
something here
take this ask her about
if they can help you with this i'm on
the phone with her ask them if they can
help you with this this is getting
everywhere it's everywhere it's getting
everywhere hello
so i need to i mean this is not
something that's uh i can wait on
because uh we have
do you have any idea how much uh
reupholstering a couch costs i mean
that's a fortune i've ruined three
couches in the last uh month and a half
um okay yeah so like i was saying uh we
could set you up and up with an
appointment um
is there any way that i can come in and
even if you don't have well i don't have
a doctor i just have i'm oh there goes
more i i i don't have a doctor i just
need somebody to
you know
maybe
as my daughter we don't have the medical
terminology but plug the hole like plug
like is there anybody that can just
lend us a
like a finger a thumb or whatever
ask her what they do
you ask she has a question miss
here's jackie do you guys have
experience in tightening someone's
sphincter
um again i think that would be a
question for one of our pt's and i had
said that we could have someone call you
guys back when they're done hello hello
we did try we did try putting a yoni egg
up there because we heard that can help
it as well it never came back out so
that's up there but it's not stopping
the leakage it's going everywhere you
got me one of those crystal eggs that's
up there and it's really open
hello
yes okay
um yes so like i said um
some of your questions i'm not able to
answer but like
i'm trying to get it i'm trying to get
the i'm trying to get the egg hang on
[Music]
hang on
don't push that's what happens every
time you
clip your nails clip your nails i've
told you to clip your nails if you keep
pushing that's what makes it go all over
the couch you already run the couch you
ruin the carpet get your fingers out of
my ass now get your fingers out of my
ass and leave i'm going to handle this
myself
okay hello what is a good time yeah
what's a good time um
so um we can have someone call you back
um in maybe around 30 minutes i just um
like i said they're with patients right
now so it would just be when they have
um some time in between can you just
talk us through this because i know can
you just help me right now with this
what would you suggest do you have a
should i put pressure on it or should i
what should i do i can't give you that
kind of advice because i am not a
medical professional i
like i said i just handle the
administration stuff so um i can have
someone call you back if you want to
leave a call back have you ever have you
ever got a like a paper cut
yes me too those are really painful
aren't they
mm-hmm
so do you want to leave a callback
number um i i'm not really at a place
where i could take a number because we
are at um
i'll be honest with you we're out in
public now so we're at the uh
we're at the mall
so i don't want to when we're using the
public phone here at the mall
so i don't want to uh wait here and then
get a call or have somebody pick it up
i'm actually embarrassed to be honest
with you
okay uh well is there another form of
communication that we could try like an
email address
what would be the uh discoloration in my
poo what is that
i again would not be able to answer that
question because i'll have my daughter
i'll have my daughter come on and
describe it to you hang on one second um
that's okay i don't
i wouldn't be able to answer that
question because i'm not a medical
professional so do but can i just tell
you so we can get a second opinion
because it's just me and i'm not a
medical professional either it's like
this greenish color but not like a
normal green it's like a like a neon
almost like really really really bright
hello um so i would just say go see a
doctor because i like i said i don't
know really
i heard do you think it could be because
of the healing crystal uh properties of
the crystal that's stuck up there like i
just want maybe it's like
oh my god
the girl over at claire's is staring at
me now the girl at claire's is staring
at me now
we're miss can we just stop can we just
stop by so that you guys can take a look
even if even if someone's not available
maybe you can take a look and give us
some advice i don't care
yeah i wouldn't be able to do that
i didn't make this puddle i mean we
don't have any other options right now
we're at the mall
everyone's staring if we can just come
by and then you can just like let us
know what to do that would be the best
i'll be at feminine i'll be honest yeah
i don't i wouldn't be able to help you
because i i wouldn't know no but we
don't know how to advise you
what do you think about i said
can we just
wait i know she said we're coming right
over but
miss let me just say something we might
i heard my daughter saying that she was
going to come right over we're not
coming right over because i have not
eaten lunch and we're going to stop at
the food court and then we'll go over so
we'll be there after lunch we'll be
there after lunch do you want us to pick
you up anything they have uh sabaro here
and they have uh chick-fil-a
and they have is there anything that we
can bring for you
uh no
any drink or anything i wouldn't come in
i mean i i don't raise my kids to show
up someplace empty-handed so that's it
just spilling again out of the back
there
i'm gonna head over to the food court
we'll see in a couple of minutes we'll
see in a couple minutes we're coming in
we're coming in get napkins get napkins
what's your name so we'll ask for you
what's your name
uh can you use a different name for this
uh no because that is my given name so
i cannot can i call you
can i call you uh marla
no i would prefer you call me by my
given name okay but i'm just gonna do
what i do
marla we're gonna be there in about 20
minutes
i'm going to stop and get a slice of
pizza
and a drink i'm willing to get you
something
uh but uh
marla you just say it and that'll be
what i'll bring you what do you want
marla
my name is
and i do not want anything but like i
said you should probably oh i'm not
gonna charge you i'm not gonna charge
you marla it's yours i wasn't
thinking about that but okay
no we'll bring it for free i'm gonna
bring you oh that's okay i don't need
anything they have rice krispie treats
no thank you oh my god what is this all
this fluid
it's green it's a light green all right
see you soon
okay have a good one youtube bye bye
anyway that was uh marla okay
um
and i think that's uh let's go get lunch
let's go get lunch
that was how we do it
[Music]
you